a me bastardo di un muro sapete che
quando ho fatto un viaggio in aereo che
dura 12 ore quando tornate a casa avete
tutto quanto il jet lag che vi bis
minchia al cervello non riuscite a
dormire un cazzo perché io stanotte non
ho dormito neanche un orario sono in
after non si vede dalle occhiaie per
niente sono tornato a casa registra
video il rancio un cazzo voglia di
cambiarmi quindi non scassato muggas lo
faccio chiusi della tutti ragazzi e
benvenute questo video sarò fa vj ma
deciso quindi di fare un video un po
particolare si tratta ragazzi del che
cosa ho comprato in giappone in realtà
ho comprato tantissimi dolci e stronzate
varie per provarli in diretta in un
video quindi non comprate giusto troppe
al cibo ci arriviamo dopo prima di tutto
passiamo alle cose non commestibile
primo oggetto di oggi allora posso posso
posso spiegare in giappone ci sono i
prize game ovvero quelle macchinette
dove tu devi muovere l'abbraccio andar
giù e prendere le cose in mezzo a tutte
quelle sono riuscito a vincere questa
tipa che ha delle tette considerevole
della madonna
pensavo ma no ma cosa facesse lo mette a
corpo devono pure montarmi e la non devo
potevo prendere la già montata che frase
brutto ho detto la mia ignoranza
quest'anima io non lo conosco per niente
però c'è un buon motivo per guardarlo
direi anzi due buoni motivi per
guardarlo che poi tra l'atro ragazzi
tutta sta roba va montata così ci vuole
questo che va messo qui voi scherzate ma
veramente lo ha messo così aveva
infilato in questo buco qua perfetto va
bene ragazzi il primo è andato passiamo
al prossimo il prossimo ragazzi e niente
popò di meno che toto ho dovuto
prenderlo immediatamente non potevo
farne a meno che il prossimo ragazzi del
più grosso di tutti quanti e non è
quello che pensate
se sempre i place game stavolta mi è
uscita una roba un po più grosso delle
tette di voi non avete idea di come
minchia ho fatto a portarlo nella
occupava metà valigia solo questo
dopodiché i ragazzi ho preso un paio di
souvenir per i miei genitori che sono un
tipo questi è una roba che va appesa al
muro ma mi piaceva tantissimo quindi
l'ho presa immediatamente
spero vivamente che i miei genitori non
guardino questo video perché sennò
appena svelato il souvenir ti piace
mamma figo
per concludere con le cose non
commestibili ho preso un ventaglio che
non aprirò perché ciò la pigrizia
nell'anima e due calamite sempre uguali
perché ci avevo la pigrizia di cercarne
i due diverse quindi non prese due
uguali ragazzi le calamite sono il
classico souvenir di quando fai un
viaggio da qualche parte e poi l'ultimo
giorno ti ricordi improvvisamente che
devi prendere un souvenir per qualcuno
sono ti fanno un buco di culo così e
prendi la prima puttanata che ti passa
di mano e quindi prendi le calamite
quindi se riceverete mai come souvenir e
in regalo una calamita sappiate che il
tipo che verrà presa si è ricordato di
voi solo all'ultimo secondo quante
amicizie o distrutto in un secondo
ed eccoci ragazzi al momento che tutti
quanti aspettavano anch'io perché non so
che cosa cazzo solo per andare ad
assaggiare ma siamo arrivati al momento
dei dolci giapponesi c'è scritto banana
non ho capito se sono caramelle o se
sono banane essiccate anno sono cos'è
sta roba
io dovrei ingurgitare questa cosa
minchia fate sa di banana l'avrei mai
detto
cazzo buonissimo
next one galan cha ha la forma di un
cornetto sto coso però non è un cornetto
si chiama khalip con sembra che qualcuno
ci sia andato su di dissenteria su un
cono gelato è normale che sappia
veramente di merda passiamo al prossimo
questo ragazzi è bellissimo perché c'è
un do rai non grigio sulla confezione
stupende che cos'è è bruttissimo a
vederlo rega che cazzo è marika mi fa
schifo casa nissan i piedi per l'amor di
dio o questo questo interessante ragazzi
questo sembra figo sono dei mini budini
bellissimo spot per noi questa canzone
rientrerà in testa per il resto delle
vostre vite mi dispiace è richiesto
intervento chirurgico
[Musica]
sa di budino non l'avrei mai detto che
idea della madonna affari budini
miniatura così di 20 o peggio in tre
secondi non te ne rendi conto
ora ogni caso a che cosa buona lo trovo
ogni tanto e ho paura di queste
confezioni le grazie ma sono biscotti
sono biscotti grazie a dio cioccolato
promosso questo ragazzi e curioso perché
c'è l'impegno di una katana era nel
reparto dolci sul serio non direi che
cosa sia prove è una katana in miniatura
tutti ma si mangia no e plastica perché
casa c'era una katana in miniatura in
mezzo al reparto dolce siete pronti per
la vita la vita vera pacchia
cos'è è bellissimo lo assaggio perché
ormai l'ho preso e vabbè però mi chiedo
lo vorrei tenere così mi sento uno
stronzo è la cosa più raccapricciante
che io abbia mai fatto in tutta non
guardate questo video vi prego è ormai è
tardi quando un [ __ ] koala ti fa
l'occhiolino ma cosa vuoi di più nella
vita sembrano biscotti per cani la
differenza da un biscotto per cani e che
sopra ci ha disegnato un [ __ ] koala
però sa di cibo per cani
ragazzi siamo arrivati al momento qui
adesso vi faccio vedere come è fatto
questo cibo e voi mi dite che cos'è che
cos'è sta roba
cazzo sa proprio di oreo sembra
un'onerosa di oreo però si chiamano nick
8 che cazzo è un nick 8 non sarebbe
stato geniale se avessi detto sociali o
leo somiglia a dio leo che cos'è e poi
tiravo poi la confezione vera degli one
cioè uno regole posso avere paura di
onde madonna e disgustoso l'odore vista
roma cos'è ma va c'è il formaggio ma non
è un no mi fa schifo papa che sa più di
piedi questo è quello di prima mese
dovrebbero essere caramelle in teoria aj
queste sono mie ragazze
ma cosa perché me le mettono così sembra
che devo prendere le pastiglie di
tachipirina e buonissimo menichini
omette via mettevi a les combes dove si
comprano prendono tornare in giappone
solo per questo l'unica roba buona che
ho mangiato dall'inizio non ci possono
creare le parti budini carne essiccata
credo sia carne essiccata a vederli
copro faccia mangiarla starò non a
queste per cani banche robben non
commestibili in realtà sto mangiando
domani sulle boe la pera cibo per cani
verrà questo e formaggio basta col
formaggio era reparto dolci porca eva
che ci fa cibo per cani e ci fanno i
formaggi
ma questo mi fa schifo questo santini fa
veramente si sa di non di piedi fa di
piedi di cadavere marcio la gioia pack
indoor aimo pesto volevo un porca eva
non i piedi maghi maghetti è mal
commestibile magari mi sto mangiando la
plastica vera l'unica cosa che so è che
era nel reparto dolci poi se qualche
bambino nel reparto giocattoli ha preso
un giocattolo e l'ha messo nel reparto
dolci io mi sto mangiando dei giocattoli
perché non si capisce un cazzo non si
capisce tutto in giapponese cosa vuoi
che capisca potrebbe tranquillamente
essere plastica non lo so tanto peggio
di così sono dei cangi fatti a caramella
bellissimo questo è commestibile neanche
buono troppo buono
amaro d'aiuto qualche [ __ ] sempre
meglio dei piedi per ora se ne sono
salvate due o tre su 20 che queste sono
rose vere cazzo ci parla nel reparto
dolci cazzo sa di rosa veramente come fa
sapre linosa provate a indovinare che
gusto sono ste pringle [ __ ] perché
tutto al formaggio perché questo
e bellissimo promette benissimo dalla
faccia propria famiglia del se fa ero
sapevo cosa poteva essere se non
formaggio pure questo [ __ ] vacca
annuncio non ho e formaggio
io vorrei sapere katsu metti il
formaggio nel reparto dove si chi è che
mette il formaggio formaggio zucchero
sono due cose diverse siamo arrivati
ragazzi alla cosa credo più [ __ ] di
tutte quante
è un distributore di caramelle del i
pokémon fottutamente geniale non ho
ancora visto se funziona prova indiretta
eppure buono e non è finita qua il coso
in alto si chiama abbattere roulette che
se tu giri questo coso ti escono delle
cose che non riuscirai mai a produrre
perché in giapponese
però ti senti figo maghette testo
bambino bruttona nostri ragazzi sono
biscotti già tutti smin chiatti
fantastico non sono al formaggio sono
alla sono sanno di dentifricio non ho la
più pallida idea di che cosa sia sta
roba ma meglio del resto sicuro perché
perché fare una caramella così grossa
minchia ma che cazzola da magna sta gara
nella godzilla cimetti 12 giorni a farla
sciogliere perché tipo gigante guarda
quanto grossa l'ultimo incredibile
l'ultimo di oggi è questo qui che si
chiama sciocco ball che possono palle al
cioccolato oppure ciò come lui e le
palle sono le sue ma bene zio ti credo
sony cioccolato dai ragazzi grazie a dio
questo era l'ultima cofito sacchetto ce
n'erano non so neanche quante il fatto è
che i ragazzi il giorno prima di partire
per tornare a casa dal giappone mi è
venuto in mente di fare questo video
quindi ho comprato 250 dolci il fatto è
che hanno dovuto portarli in aereo e non
ci stava assolutamente un cazzo in
valigia perché c'era anche questo in
valigia che comprimeva tutto quanto ho
dovuto mettere vestiti scarpe
caramelle e questo tutto insieme credevo
di trovare tutto quanto spappolato
invece no grazie a dio per questo video
vi sia piaciuto è stato alquanto
formaggio zoe cedute un misto di sapori
tra carne essiccata formaggio e
caramelle che non avete idea però che vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi un pollicioni su
anche per lui che sicuramente si è
divertito di più di me tranquillo si è
mangiato io per tutti e due tu sei già
obeso 6 ce n'è bisogno
spero che mi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa è
piaciuto sul commento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook è corredato
da descrizione 60 siti siete in ci
vediamo prossimo video e vorrei chiudere
però non mi ricordo dove ho messo
telecomando prima di partire dal
giappone facciamo con le forbici ragazzi